Taïga, Steppe,
Toundra, des milliers de lacs.
Avec ses espaces vierges,
la Sibérie a offert
ses noms à la géographie du monde.
Je pars pour remonter le temps
sur plusieurs milliers de kilomètres,
depuis le lac Baïkal
jusqu'aux montagnes de l'Oural,
frontière symbolique avec l'Occident.
Sans sabre,
je voyage dans le sens opposé,
emprunté par les Cosaques
partis conquérir la Sibérie.
Je veux partager
des instants de vie
avec ceux
qui habitent depuis toujours ici.
Au rythme du Transsibérien,
je longe Sa Majesté le Baïkal.
J'aime voyager en train.
Surtout ici, en Russie.
À cinq fuseaux
horaires de la capitale,
je vis comme tous
à l'heure de Moscou.
Dans un tel pays,
rien n'est vraiment ordinaire.
On n'y rencontre pas
de simples individus,
mais des destins.
Face à l'étendue
blanche du plus grand
et du plus profond lac du monde,
je reçois de plein fouet
le mythe
de la Sibérie tout entière.
J'ai rejoint la caravane
des chasseurs de phoques.
Elle quitte le kolkhoze Pobieda,
emmenant avec elle
tout le nécessaire pour survivre
un mois sur la glace.
Un peu de vodka
pour se réchauffer le cœur,
sans oublier de trinquer
avec le dieu Bourcane,
afin d'obtenir sa protection.
Avec les chasseurs,
je roule 300 kilomètres vers le Sud.
Le voyage n'est pas sans danger.
Le jour,
l'atmosphère se réchauffe.
C'est le moment.
Les phoques sortent de leur trou
pour se chauffer au soleil.
L'hiver,
le Baïkal n'est plus un lac.
J'admire un véritable glacier
enchâssé entre les montagnes.
Ces hommes
sont les seuls autorisés
à tuer jusqu'à
6 000 phoques chaque année.
Cette chasse
est indispensable au maintien
du bon équilibre
de la population animale.
Avec la crise,
les chasseurs vivent dans la misère.
Ils ne tuent
que 2 à 3 000 bêtes par saison.
De toute façon,
leur kolkhoze ne possède
ni la technologie,
ni le marché nécessaire
pour traiter
un plus grand nombre de peaux.
C'est notre travail.
Chasseurs de phoques.
À chacun le sien.
Tout ça, c'est traditionnel,
on ne peut pas l'abandonner.
Il faut le faire
de manière raisonnable.
Merci à Anton, Volodia et Boris
de m'avoir permis
de vous accompagner.
Je file vers le Nord
et remonte la vallée de Chimqui.
J'ai pris de l'altitude.
Ici, le vent a balayé la neige.
Dans chaque village,
on a l'impression
qu'il n'y a pas âme qui vive.
En marchant
au milieu des maisons,
je rencontre Sacha, avec lui,
j'échappe
au cycle infernal de la vie.
La majorité
de la population russe est chrétienne.
Nous, les Bouriates,
nous sommes bouddhistes.
À l'époque soviétique,
notre culte était interdit
et le monastère
derrière moi avait été détruit.
Du temps des Soviets,
tous nos rites
se déroulaient en cachette.
Après l'écroulement
du régime communiste en 1990,
des datsans et des églises
ont été reconstruits.
Tout est redevenu comme avant.
Je ne rêve pas.
Je suis en Sibérie
et non pas au Tibet, à Lhassa.
Depuis longtemps,
on a conservé notre religion
de génération en génération.
Je tiens tout cela
de mes grands-parents,
moi je continue.
Plus tard, grâce à nous,
cela va continuer pour nos enfants.
Le bouddhisme existe ici
depuis la nuit des temps.
Sasha m'apprend
que le bouddhisme
et le chamanisme sont intimement liés.
Au milieu des sources sacrées,
je regarde ces bouts de tissu
sur lesquels sont imprimées
des formules implorant
la bénédiction des dieux.
Le vent les caresse
et les disperse dans l'espace.
Encore une nouvelle incantation.
Intrigué,
je n'ai plus qu'une envie,
rencontrer un chamane.
Je crois tout savoir.
Le chamane est consulté
pour obtenir
la guérison, des réponses
ou pour accompagner
l'âme d'un défunt dans l'autre monde.
Grâce à Sasha,
je suis prêt pour assister
à une séance d'exorcisme.
Ton problème est grave ?
Mes chevaux
sont très nerveux en ce moment.
J'ai l'impression
qu'on leur a jeté un sort.
Tout va mieux
pour les chevaux de Sasha.
Direction la maison.
Éléna nous préparent
un repas familial,
une recette locale.
Je prépare un plat
traditionnel bouriate.
J'utilise de la viande
de porc et de bœuf.
On peut prendre du mouton.
Je les passe au hachoir,
ajouter de l'ail,
de l'oignon et du poivre.
Je n'y connais rien en cuisine.
Je préfère m'occuper des chevaux.
Si à chaque rencontre
ma soif est étanchée,
j'ai une faim vorace.
Celle d'en savoir plus et d'aller loin.
Je continue mon chemin en MI-8,
fabrication soviétique.
Bercé par les vibrations
de cet engin que je connais bien,
direction Tours Hakeim,
dans les monts Saïan.
À Tour Hakeim,
comme partout en Sibérie,
on étend son linge dehors.
Une façon originale de le repasser.
Ostorozhno, fais gaffe en russe.
Même avec l'habitude de la neige,
tout peut arriver.
On m'a prévenu.
Je peux avoir ici
à nouveau le plaisir
de rencontrer
des éleveurs de rennes.
Où allez-vous ?
On est plusieurs à vivre
au bord du fleuve Ienisseï.
Combien de temps
pour arriver à votre campement ?
Une journée entière.
Je voudrais aussi
chevaucher un renne,
mais je dois rencontrer les autorités
de la réserve naturelle d'Asace.
Des officiels,
ce n'est pas ce que je préfère.
Le chef est sympa.
Il s'appelle Tarass Turba.
Chez nous,
l'hiver est très rigoureux,
car nous sommes proches
des régions polaires.
La température descend à moins 40,
voire moins 50 degré.
En revanche,
l'été est chaud,
mais trop court.
On ne peut pas dire que c'est dû
aux changements climatiques.
Les chamanes sont les seuls
capables de faire des prévisions.
Sans hésiter,
j'ai accepté d'accompagner Tarass
et ses collègues pour une virée.
Destination, le lac Azak
pour une partie de pêche.
Du poisson,
une cabane, de la chaleur
et sans doute
à boire et à manger.
Elle est solide la glace ?
Ça fait
20 centimètres d'épaisseur.
Il commence à faire très froid.
Après le jour de L'an, avec le gel,
ça va descendre
en dessous de moins 40.
Et ça va encore épaissir.
On a relevé les filets
et attrapé cinq poissons.
Il faut reboucher
les trous dans la glace
ensuite,
on retourne au campement.
Alexandre m'entraîne
jusqu'au campement
des éleveurs de rennes.
Ils n'ont que deux bêtes utilisées
pour le transport des marchandises.
La dame aperçue
à Tour Hakeim n'est pas là.
En revanche, le Tchoum
et ses occupants sont accueillants.
Direction la sortie.
Un vrai toit
sous lequel nous attend un repas.
Avec toute ma bande
habillée en treillis,
on est devenus
plus que de bons amis.
En Sibérie,
on boit pour s'évader,
se réchauffer
le corps et l'esprit.
Justement,
après quelques verres,
Alexandre chasse
les mauvais esprits
qui de leur côté,
ont déjà réussi à dissiper
la brume des vapeurs d'alcool.
Do svidaniya.
Au revoir Tarass,
Yvon et Alexandre.
Longue vie à tous !
Grâce aux chamanes,
j'ai rejoint sur un tapis volant
les rives du fleuve Ienisseï.
Un monument
m'indique que j'ai atteint
le centre géographique de l'Asie.
Je suis à Kyzyl,
capitale de la région de Touva.
Comme dans
l'Empire russe d'aujourd'hui,
la chute du Mur
n'a pas entraîné
celle des idoles communistes.
Au présent,
le passé est toujours là.
Lénine me montre le chemin
et je retrouve
Nikolaï Ivanovitch, un scientifique.
Nous possédons
un environnement naturel très varié.
Nous avons des montagnes,
la Toundra, la Taïga, des Steppes,
même des régions désertiques.
Bien sûr, nous avons
des problèmes écologiques.
Derrière nous,
on voit ce brouillard, le smog
qui stagne au-dessus
de la ville de Kyzyl.
C'est le même phénomène
au-dessus de chaque village à Touva.
Les maisons
sont chauffées au charbon
et ce charbon
a une haute teneur en carbone.
La combustion
du charbon est incomplète.
Elle dégage des gaz
et des particules qui s'échappent
par les cheminées
vers l'atmosphère.
J'apprends que le chauffage
au charbon est interdit
depuis longtemps
dans les villes européennes.
Grâce aux ressources
naturelles inépuisables de la Sibérie,
ce n'est pas près
de changer en Russie.
Dans l'atmosphère de cette ville
qui semble
vivre à l'heure soviétique,
je désire m'imprégner
de la culture traditionnelle de Touva.
Spécialités locales,
les chants de gorge
dont Iouri Ivanovitch est
l'un des plus fervents défenseurs.
C'est très important
de conserver les modèles
de la culture du folklore russe,
qui sont menacés de disparition.
Car leurs représentants
vieillissent inexorablement
et meurent peu à peu.
Je fais partie
de l'ethnie des khakhasses.
Notre république est située
au Nord de celle de Touva.
La langue de notre peuple,
les khakasses
ressemblent à celles des Tatars
et des Iakoutes.
Nous possédons
une physionomie proche de la leur.
Nous ressemblons
aux habitants de l'Asie centrale.
À Touva,
il y a un mélange
de différentes populations.
Nous avons non seulement
conservé toutes nos cultures,
mais aussi les modes de vie
traditionnels de notre région.
Chez nous plus qu'ailleurs,
l'élevage et l'agriculture
ont gardé leurs racines ancestrales.
Tu t'en rendra compte
lorsque tu traverseras Touva.
Ici, c'est vraiment unique.
Les gens vivent sans l'eau courante,
comme avant.
Ils habitent dans des yourtes.
L'été, comme l'hiver.
On possède
plus de 50 têtes de bétail.
Dans la steppe,
il y en a encore plus.
On vit ainsi.
Malgré le froid intense,
il faut vivre et travailler.
Nos moutons,
c'est notre richesse vivante.
Avec mon chauffeur,
nous sommes invités
à boire la boisson traditionnelle,
faite avec du lait fermenté.
À l'intérieur,
tout le confort nécessaire.
Et Olga nous montre fièrement
les photos de ses petits-enfants.
Je suis déjà parti
depuis plus d'un mois
et je tente
de respecter un plan imprévu.
Toujours à l'heure de Moscou,
je saute
dans un Transsibérien de passage.
Cap au Nord.
À Tomsk, Tchekhov
me souhaite la bienvenue,
mais lui n'a pas aimé la ville.
Anton disait :
Rien dans la vie ne vaut la peine
de donner au diable
la plus petite parcelle de son âme.
Merci Vladimir Oulianov
de ne pas avoir abîmé celle de Tomsk.
Malgré les bouleversements de l'histoire,
cette cité aujourd'hui jeune
est toujours tolérante
envers les cultures étrangères.
Baptisé orthodoxe russe,
je préfère pratiquer l'improbable
plus que l'inexorable.
En revanche,
je suis très attaché aux traditions
de ce qui aurait pu être mon pays.
Les églises ici,
cela ne manque pas.
J'apprends que le père Andrey
dirigeant la destinée des fameux
vieux-croyants
de la région m'attend.
Je fonce
à la rencontre du temps perdu
et des barbus traqués
en leur temps par Pierre le Grand.
Quelle est la différence
entre les orthodoxes
et les vieux-croyants ?
Chez nous,
dans la véritable sainte Russie,
nous les vieux-croyants,
on fait le signe de croix
avec deux doigts
représentant Dieu
et Jésus-Christ.
Les orthodoxes
de l'Église officielle font
ce même signe avec trois doigts,
symbole de la Sainte Trinité.
Nous,
nous prions en disant :
Jésus, Fils de Dieu,
aies pitié de nous pauvres pécheurs.
Alors que l'Église officielle
inverse les mots de cette prière.
Les chants religieux
sont effectués à plusieurs voix,
alors que nous,
nous chantons à l'unisson.
L'ensemble du chœur chante,
mais le son
est celui d'une seule voix.
Blagodaryu vas.
Après avoir remercié Sa Sainteté
en langue russe recherché,
je me rends
à quelques kilomètres de là,
à Chernaya Rijeka,
petite rivière Noire.
J'ai rendez-vous
avec Monsieur et Madame Tatar.
Ce peuple n'évoque pour moi
que l'image du sabre
destructeur d'Ivan le Terrible.
En cherchant la maison
de Raïssa et de Boris,
mon regard est attiré
par une mosquée.
J'y entre,
qui verra, vivra.
Nous les Tatars,
nous sommes très unis.
Nos racines sont ici, en Sibérie.
À l'époque d'Ivan le Terrible,
les Tatars se sont
scindés en deux groupes.
Le tsar a expédié
une partie en Crimée au soleil
et l'autre,
il l'a envoyé en Sibérie,
où ils ont fondé la ville de Tomsk.
C'est donc nos ancêtres
qui ont créé cette ville.
Il n'y a qu'un seul Dieu,
mais il y a plusieurs religions.
Chez nous,
il y a des mariages mixtes.
Les musulmans
et les orthodoxes se marient.
Ça n'a pas d'importance,
s'ils respectent leurs parents.
Tous vivent ici
avec leurs enfants.
Une journée de folie.
À 200 mètres de là,
Irina et Rouslan se marient.
Ça tombe bien,
j'ai envie de rire
et une faim de loup.
Nous respectons
les traditions russes,
la religion russe,
l'orthodoxie, le christianisme.
Je suis musulmane.
Rouslan et moi,
on s'est rencontrés il y a longtemps.
Nous avons grandi ensemble.
Nous nous connaissons très bien.
C'est pourquoi
on a décidé de nous marier
pour fonder une famille.
J'espère que bientôt,
nous aurons un enfant.
On veut beaucoup d'enfants.
Nos invités
nous offrent plein de cadeaux.
On boit, on danse.
Les jeunes, les vieux,
tous jettent
des pièces de monnaie en l'air,
ils cachent
des billets de banque.
Tout le monde le fait et nous,
on doit ramasser tout cet argent.
Ils nous souhaitent ainsi la solidité
et la richesse pour notre couple.
Et cette richesse,
c'est Dieu qui nous la donnera.
Si Dieu veille
sur le bonheur d'Irina et de Rouslan,
il n'a rien pu faire autrefois ici,
contre le diable.
Sur ordre de Staline,
le Transsibérien
ouvrait les portes du cauchemar
pour des centaines
de milliers de déportés.
Gens aisés, intellectuels
ou opposants supposés
de toutes nationalités
ont connu la terreur
dans les sinistres
geôles du NKVD,
avant d'être condamnés.
Je les imagine catapultés
sur les rives du fleuve Ob.
Beau poisson.
J'en prends souvent des gros,
parfois plus de dix kilos.
J'ai l'impression
de rencontrer un rescapé du goulag.
Anton m'invite à me réchauffer
dans son univers habituel.
Il fait très froid.
Même la vodka a gelé,
c'est terrible.
Je ne sais pas
quelle température il fait dehors.
Tu crois qu'il fait combien ?
Moins de 45 degrés,
sans aucun doute.
La bouteille
de vodka était au frais.
Malgré ses 40 degrés, elle a gelé.
C'est sûr, moins de 45.
Cette vodka est
de mauvaise qualité.
C'est devenu une habitude.
On m'offre
le meilleur à chaque fois.
Du sterling
finement découpé.
Je n'ai pas froid aux yeux.
Avec les parents d'Anton,
j'entame une conversation
sur un sujet brûlant.
Tu as vu comme la nature
est sauvage chez nous.
C'est vierge.
C'est pour cela
qu'on les a menés ici.
Il n'y a aucun
moyen de communication.
On ne peut s'enfuir,
nulle part où aller.
Même Staline
avait été exilé ici.
À Nadym ?
- Oui, tout près d'ici.
Il n'est pas resté
longtemps à Nadym.
Bien sûr.
Lui au moins, il s'est enfui.
Assez de déportés
politiques se sont retrouvés
dans cette région.
Aujourd'hui, on peut
utiliser des petits avions.
Avant,
il n'y avait rien.
Il n'y avait que les chevaux
pour aller jusqu'à Tomsk.
Et l'été,
on passait par le fleuve.
C'était une immense prison,
sans barbelé.
Ça remonte,
moins de 39 degrés.
Frigorifié,
j'apprends un épisode passé
sous silence
pendant soixante ans.
Une tragédie programmée
ou un manque de coordination
dans la chaîne du goulag.
Sur ce fleuve gelé,
l'ile Nazino était
devenue l'île aux cannibales.
Staline, l'homme d'acier,
y a fait débarquer
6000 éléments
socialement nuisibles.
Sans provisions, ni outils,
ils meurent de faim,
au point de s'entre dévorer.
Retour à une réalité plus gaie,
faire son marché
pour acheter
du poisson fraîchement pêché.
Qui aime le brochet ?
C'est bon à manger.
Celui-ci,
il coûte 500 roubles le kilo.
À part Abel,
j'ai rencontré Boris.
Bien accroché,
je l'accompagne sur le stade
d'un des sports
favoris d'hiver en Russie.
Avec seulement
cinq filets bien installés,
on attrape 40 kilos
de poisson par jour.
C'est formidable
et pas compliqué.
Tu as compris ?
Bien entendu,
Boris m'invite à déjeuner.
Rapidement,
je me retrouve une fois de plus
au chaud et en famille.
Buvons à la santé de nos invités.
Pas moi, je conduis.
Ne lui en donne pas,
il y en aura plus pour les autres.
Parle-moi des poissons
que vous pêchez.
Les poissons considérés
comme les meilleurs
sont le sterling,
l'esturgeon, la nelma.
La nelma est très salée.
Dans nos fleuves,
on pêche des poissons magnifiques.
Le brochet, le carassin, le cogne
et bien d'autres encore.
Suivant la profondeur,
on trouve aussi le sandre.
Sa chair est
très tendre, très agréable.
Le caviar d'esturgeon
est très apprécié.
C'est un véritable régal.
Un plat de roi.
Je coupe la parole à Boris
pour une nouvelle
question sur le passé.
Staline représente quoi pour toi ?
Pour moi,
Staline était discipliné.
Il faisait régner l'ordre.
Tu comprends ?
Pour notre
génération de gens âgés,
aujourd'hui,
tout s'est effondré.
Il faut de l'ordre.
Ça nous met en colère.
Aujourd'hui, chacun
agit à sa guise, dans le foutoir.
C'est tout
et n'importe quoi.
Avant, l'ordre régnait.
Il y avait de la discipline,
aujourd'hui, plus de discipline.
Quand on chasse le naturel,
il revient toujours au galop.
Le bruit des chevaux
me fait oublier celui du passé
qui a souvent
rythmé mes rencontres
avec l'ancienne génération.
Je ne peux pas leur en vouloir
de regretter
le temps de l'URSS.
À la lisière
des grandes agglomérations,
le temps s'est arrêté.
Rien n'a changé
pour les habitants en Sibérie.
J'ai déjà vécu parmi
les peuples du nord de ce pays,
une mosaïque d'ethnie
Evenks, Nénètses, Dolganes
vivant au-delà
du cercle polaire.
Surpris, je découvre
que les selkoupes habitent ici.
Je m'aperçois qu'ils ressemblent
à tous les Russes
rencontrés dans le métro de Moscow.
Sauf que les selkoupes possèdent ici
un véritable
trésor sous leurs pieds.
Je pose une
de mes questions favorites à Ivan.
Tu as l'âme russe
ou l'âme selkoupe ?
Avant tout,
je suis selkoupe.
Mais en réalité,
âme russe ou âme selkoupe,
cela ne veut rien dire pour moi.
Je suis intimement lié à la forêt,
au fleuve,
aux poissons, aux gibiers.
Je suis un homme de la nature.
Sans la pêche, sans la chasse,
sans ces sensations,
je ne peux pas vivre.
Lorsque je pars
une semaine en ville,
au bout de deux jours,
je n'en peux plus.
Plus rien ne m'intéresse.
Je n'aime pas
les bars, les discothèques.
Je brûle avec le désir
de revenir
dans ma maison.
J'ai un tel caractère
qu'après deux jours passés en ville,
je commence à m'énerver.
Je sens que je dois
absolument rentrer.
La conduite de gaz
passe à 12 kilomètres d'ici.
Oui, on est allé
voir les tuyaux de gaz.
On a vu les tuyaux,
le gaz passe bien là,
mais autour de la conduite,
la nature a été dévastée.
C'est le vide.
Après, on a repris
notre vie de tous les jours.
Je ne comprends pas
la politique du gouvernement.
On vit sur des gisements
de gaz et de pétrole.
Les tuyaux
passent sous nos pieds,
mais nous
n'en tirons aucun profit.
En Occident, ils ont tout.
C'est incroyable.
Et chez nous,
en Sibérie, on n'a rien.
On vit comme avant.
Je ne comprends pas.
Je suis allé
en mission au Canada,
qui ne possède de réserves
comparables aux nôtres.
Dans le Nord, le niveau de vie
est extraordinaire.
Au Canada,
le gouvernement agit
pour le bien-être du peuple.
Et chez nous,
il ne pense qu'à ses profits.
Je ne suis plus loin de Moscou,
à peine 2000 kilomètres.
Je domine la capitale
de l'eldorado sibérien,
située dans une région colonisée
5 000 ans auparavant
par les chasseurs de mammouths.
Bâtie grâce à l'argent
du gaz et du pétrole,
la ville de Khanty-Mansiysk
est la fierté
de la galaxie Gazprom,
le mastodonte
de l'énergie en Russie.
Le sol gelé
est gorgé de pétrole
qu'il est impossible
de construire des immeubles
de plus de 12 étages.
Les compagnies pétrolières
de ce Koweït City de Sibérie
représente-t-elle un danger ?
C'est bien d'extraire
les richesses de notre sous-sol,
mais le faire de façon
intensive n'est pas raisonnable.
Les dirigeants des grandes
compagnies doivent comprendre
que des hommes travaillent ici.
Qu'ils vivent ici.
Il faut qu'ils protègent
notre environnement naturel
pour le bien-être de la population.
Nous aimons tous la nature.
Nous avons besoin
de nos rivières et de nos forêts,
de la pêche et la chasse.
Ils doivent tout prévoir
pour protéger la population.
Il faut que Moscou pense à nous
et aux générations futures.
Il faut tout faire pour cela
dans notre magnifique région.
Bravo Mikhaïl.
J'espère que tu seras entendu.
Ces bâtiments sont
construits sur le permafrost,
la terre gelée en permanence.
Le sol ne dégèle
que sur une faible profondeur
pendant le très court été.
La ville est
comme une île posée
au milieu des plus
grands marécages du monde,
qui s'étale
sur cinq millions d'hectares.
C'est un phénomène
naturel unique au monde.
Aussi unique
que la profondeur du lac Baïkal.
Si en Occident,
on sait que le Baïkal contient
10 pour cent
de nos réserves d'eau douce,
en revanche,
très peu de gens
au-delà de l'ex rideau de fer
connaissent l'existence
de ces marécages.
Un produit organique
constitué de carbone,
la tourbe s'est accumulée
dans ces marécages.
Tout le monde
sait que lors du dégel,
cela provoque
un dégagement de méthane
qui est responsable du réchauffement
climatique subi par notre planète.
On peut affirmer
que les marécages
de la Sibérie occidentale
renferment depuis
des milliers d'années
du carbone,
en quantités énormes.
Si le réchauffement
climatique s'accélère,
la glace pourrait
libérer ce gaz qui s'est accumulé.
La fonte des glaces
en Sibérie constitue
un problème
fondamental pour l'humanité.
Si ce processus
de gel dégel s'accentue,
la situation dans le Nord-Ouest de
la Sibérie peut devenir catastrophique.
J'ai froid
dans le dos à nouveau.
Mon Dieu,
que c'est grand la Sibérie.
Direction, la sérénité
et la quiétude
avec les éleveurs de rennes
qui vivent au pied
des montagnes de l'Oural,
comme les selkoupes,
les Komis
n'ont pas la physionomie
à laquelle je m'attendais
et ils vivent toujours
à l'heure de l'ancien régime.
Chacune de nos brigades possède
plus de 180 têtes de bétail.
En ce moment,
on en a rassemblé une trentaine.
Mickaël, c'est le plus âgé.
Dans les autres brigades
où tu vas aller,
ils sont tous jeunes.
Quatre familles
vivent dans cette isba perdue
au fond de nulle part.
Après les présentations d'usage,
elles m'adoptent
sans me poser plus de questions.
Ma seule inquiétude
qui va vite se dissiper,
communiquer avec
le kolkhoze de Saran Paolo,
situé à 300 kilomètres de Taïga.
Cette radio
fonctionne très bien.
Je l'ai déjà utilisée.
C'était il y a 20 ans,
chez les éleveurs
de reines Evenks du Kamchatka,
à sept fuseaux horaires de là.
Rapidement, la glace est
rompue entre moi et Volodia.
Nous sommes des Komis,
des émigrés
qui ont traversé l'Oural.
Ils ont tous émigré.
Nos pères
et nos grands-pères.
Tous se sont
enfuis depuis le Nord.
Ils avaient des rennes là-bas.
Ils ont couru dans toutes
les directions suite à la répression.
Staline pourchassait les koulaks.
C'est pour cela
que mes parents sont arrivés ici.
Nous sommes nés
et nous avons grandi ici.
On vient
de la région de Mourmansk,
de la Carélie pour atterrir ici.
On est des Komis,
de l'Union soviétique.
Auparavant,
on parlait plusieurs langues,
environ quatre.
Mansi, le komi,
le khanty, le russe.
Maintenant,
nous parlons tous le russe.
C'est devenu
la langue commune.
Avant, les rennes
étaient plus nombreux.
On en possédait beaucoup.
Auparavant,
l'État nous aidait.
La reproduction s'effectue
dans de mauvaises conditions,
avec des pertes.
Il y a aussi les loups,
de plus en plus nombreux.
Avec les loups,
cela devient difficile.
Ils tuent beaucoup de nos bêtes.
S'il y avait moins de loups,
tout irait mieux.
Je passe ainsi
trois jours et trois nuits
avec mes nouveaux amis,
mes compagnons de fortune, de la vie.
Dès le matin, c'est parti.
Vers où ?
Je ne cherche pas à le comprendre.
Toujours pas moins de 40.
La tête me tourne
et pour une fois,
ce n'est pas la vodka.
Plus rien à comprendre.
Ils parlent tous
dans leur langue, le khanty.
Nous sommes
les rois du monde dehors,
vêtements en peau de renne.
À l'intérieur,
excellent steak de renne garanti.
Comment tu vois le futur ?
Le futur,
nos parents nous disaient :
"Allez à l'école,
apprenez, apprenez".
L'élevage de rennes, c'est fini.
On est devenu adulte,
on a une famille
et on dit la même chose à nos enfants.
Après nous,
ils seront encore là
et on leur aura tout appris.
Volodia Raïssa entonne :
Il est temps de vous coucher.
Pardonnez-moi de vous quitter.
Demain, je dois
franchir la frontière de l'Oural
pour rejoindre l'Occident.
J'en suis certain,
je le dis à vous tous,
tous les Ivan
et toutes les Olga,
chacun de notre côté,
nous continuerons
à vivre de simples
moments d'éternité
sans cesse renouvelée.